I want to ask you about about about the
movie paranoia in this scene in this
movie you have a very intimate love
scene I'll say sex scene because I think
we're all adults here yeah and you
should go to your room we should have a
little room that Andy goes up to we know
we shouldn't come on
we shouldn't it be fun you have a very
intimate scene with Liam Hemsworth and
and how do you I was just thinking
before that you you were trying to put
him at ease because he thought he was a
little nervous about the sex scene he
was really nervous I mean I guess it's
it can't I mean guys typically are in
those sort of scenes or situations and
he was really really yeah nervous and
the whole crew everybody's tired we've
been shooting all day it had been a long
long day and to kind of um well I was
returning a watch to the prop truck and
when I was there I noticed that there
was a large black dildo are you asking
us because I can't help you with that I
mean I was struggling it's like a large
dark colored phallus no it was a big
black dildo anyways um kind of discarded
on the side and and I asked of course as
you do when you find a dildo lying
around you asked if you can please use
it or borrow it I'm on that one yeah the
former is always better yeah and so I
asked the prop guy if I could borrow it
I go to the bed pull it into the bed
with with us you know and and I made
sure that we had the scene I asked the
director Robert Luketic if we got the
take he said yes gave me the signal and
so in the scene you know he's supposed
to passionately grab my arm and turn me
around and I just substituted my arm for
the dildo and
so wait so he grabs that Zelda what was
this reaction well as you can imagine he
was slightly surprised the words that he
wasn't surprised
oh yeah well whatever this happens every
time bite or upper arms which were very
strange arm all right paranoia it's a
corporate espionage thriller we have a
clip here from the film anything we need
to know for this scene well um there are
no sorry to disappoint there are no
black dildos in this scene but you
should stay tuned because it's still
good
well you've lost us now black of creamy
sugar he's stalking me now
I just want to know your name why so you
can poke me friendly ask for my number
or you could just give me your number
you're not relationship material
relationship you're looking for
relationship I love relationships I'm
great relationships no actually I'm just
trying to get rid of you nicely didn't
we have sex
I have a thing for bridge-and-tunnel
guys when I drink you just call me
bridge and thumb you took me out for
cheese fries cheese fries oh then why
then your the night of your life
yours not mine Oh
that's right right there